good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's something you
probably didn't know
congresswoman Alexandria Kazuya Cortez
the voice of the streets actually grew
up in an idyllic little town 45 miles
north of New York City it's called
Yorktown Heights you never know it from
listening to a recent race baiting but
the population of Alexandria Cascio
Cortez's hometown is over 90% white the
median family income there is more than
double the national average real estate
listings show million-dollar homes on
big pieces of gated property it is not
Queens it is a very nice place Yorktown
Heights is so affluent and so peaceful
in fact it doesn't need its own Police
Department instead it relies in the 59
man force that protects the larger town
around it this is the hood that spawned
Alexandria Acacio Cortez one of the
country's most privileged
revolutionaries she called herself sandy
Cortez back then she imagined that every
place could be just like Yorktown
Heights if only we got rid of the police
and apparently she still believes that
it's funny because when people ask me
what does a world where we defund the
police we're you know defunding police
looks like I tell them it looks like a
suburb it looks like a suburb
unfortunately not everyone lives in a
suburb is placid and protected as the
one sandy Cortes grew up in all big
sails and pool parties cities like st.
Louis and Baltimore are more violent
than El Salvador and they're getting
more dangerous by the day in Milwaukee
homicides have risen nearly 40 percent
just this year killings there could soon
break the city's all-time record that's
likely to happen soon in Chicago and
Kansas City just this weekend in the
city of Chicago 64 people were shot and
11 murdered 11 corpses in one weekend
none of those people died because they
were too many cops on the street they
died because thanks in part to
sloganeering from pampered dilettante
like sandy Cortes there were too few
cops less law enforcement in dangerous
places means more killings there's not
much debate
about that at least not among adults New
York City disbanded its plainclothes
police unit and cut funding for the NYPD
by a billion dollars the result
shootings in New York are up more than
200 percent compared to this time just
last year murders are up 21% burglaries
have risen 30% it is the most dangerous
time to live in New York City in a
quarter century just last night an
infant was shot to death while sleeping
in a stroller at a cookout in Brooklyn
Mayor Bill de Blasio who's almost
single-handedly destroyed that city
describe the child's murder as so
painful then de Blasio move forward with
his plans to disable the NYPD he
canceled the hiring of more than a
thousand cops he announced that police
will no longer keep the schools safe how
will this end we know very well how it
will end more poor children will die
that will not affect bill de blasio
though his family will remain protected
by armed security paid for by taxpayers
so will sandy Cortes so will Barack
Obama so will the rest of the
politicians calling for taking away your
protection
they will never suffer the consequences
and that's why they're for it the folks
in law enforcement that share the goals
of reimagining police reimagining
policing in the 21st century rethinking
and reimagining policing community
efforts to reimagine policing to
reimagine policing we have the reimagine
with policing looks like reimagining
policing reimagining our Public Safety
reimagine a citizen led approach you can
begin to reimagine law enforcement
reimagine public safety in this country
what can we do to reimagine Public
Safety reimagining Public Safety to
reimagine public safety we must
reimagine what Public Safety looks like
we must reimagine public safety that's
their new talking point it was devised
by some pollster at the DNC and they're
all faithfully repeating it like the
robots they are but what exactly does it
mean mark McCloskey doesn't have to
imagine he was a test case for
reimagined Public Safety when a mob
showed up outside his home and
threatened his life
the police never came McClosky and his
wife had no choice but to defend
themselves
[Music]
[Applause]
for centuries since the beginning of
recorded history self-defense has been
the most basic principle of civilization
but now that we've reimagined public
safety it's illegal
watch CNN's resident bodybuilder
explained the new standard keep in mind
as you watch that the guy doing the
lecturing in this tape has repeatedly
threatened violence against others for
invading his personal space but he gets
to do that
his brother is the governor they did not
go up your steps they didn't go to your
house they didn't touch you they didn't
try to enter your home they didn't try
to do anything to your kids but you say
you were assaulted you're using the
civil definition of that which is that
you had the apprehension that something
bad was going to happen to you but
nothing did but to call terrorism when
the people are there protesting how the
community is treated by the police is a
little bit of reverse psychology at a
minimum is it not now it's hard to know
exactly what the CNN anchor was trying
to say some of those sentences didn't
make sense but you get the larger point
homeowners who try to protect themselves
from violence are the real terrorists
now and they must be punished
increasingly they are punished listen to
the local political hacks / prosecutor
in st. Louis threatened to hurt the
McCluskey's for daring to defend
themselves I am disturbed by the events
that occurred over this weekend where
there were peaceful protesters who are
met with guns and a violent assault
since learning of these events over this
weekend I work with the public and the
police to investigate these tragic
events I will use every extent of
Missouri law to hold individuals
accountable turns out she wasn't
bluffing just a few days ago police
raided the McCluskey's home and
reportedly seized the firearms they had
used to protect themselves now